on pourrait presque se faire un petit
jeu d'osley sur la table comme ça
regardez alors ici on a les nouveaux
airpods pro 2e génération là on a la
première génération on pourrait croire
que c'est la même chose regardez j'ai
même aux oreilles comme ça directement
là il se ressemble oui mais pas tant que
ça alors aujourd'hui on fait quoi
aujourd'hui on va regarder les airpods
pro deuxième génération on va essayer de
comprendre ce qu'appelait lui faire ici
on va regarder si le son est bon si le
son est bonne qualité et s'ils sont
faits pour vous et moi c'est marrant
parce que ça fait quoi allez une
demi-heure que je les aux oreilles je
regardais tout à l'heure une vidéo du
Grand JD sur Stupeflip et puis là vous
voyez je suis là je suis en forme je
vous parle directement je les ai presque
oublié d'ailleurs j'ai hop là je vais
les enlever voilà on se parle
aujourd'hui des airpods pro deuxième
génération d'Apple c'est parti
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisée en partenariat avec rhinoshield
parce que vos airpods Pro peut venir les
protéger avec une coque et il faut
savoir qu'à l'occasion de la sortie des
iPhone 14 vous avez -15% de remise avec
le code gros 22
grrr22 remis sur tout le site
profitez-en alors rhinoshield j'en ai
déjà parlé vous avez énormément de
produits pour tout le monde pour les
iPhone protection d'écran pour vos
airpods pro pour votre Apple watch mais
là on va se concentrer sur les airpods
pro rhinocchi proposera très bientôt des
coques pour vos airpods Pro 2 venez vous
inscrire via le lien que vous avez en
bas dans la description pour être
informé dès que les produits sortiront
alors vous le savez c'est pas une
nouveauté chez rinoshield il y a
beaucoup de produits beaucoup de
collaboration dans différents univers
regardez là toutes les coques que vous
allez pouvoir retrouver pour vos airpods
Lord Of The Ring League of Legends
Marvel et compagnie vous avez One Piece
par exemple avec différents designs qui
sont vraiment super canon pareil pour
Marvel vous avez du je suis groot du
Black Widow les Avengers Spider-Man j'en
passais des meilleurs également du Star
Wars avec du jazz Jack Boeing vous avez
du Maître Yoda j'adore enfin bref il y
en a de tous les côtés Game of Thrones
également énormément de collaboration je
vous invite à venir jeter un coup d'oeil
via le lien que je vous mets juste en
bas dans la description n'oubliez pas
que les produits de rhinoshield sont
compatibles maxife sur vos solides suite
vos codes clients vos modélix et si vous
avez un iPhone vous avez également des
protections en verre trempé je vous
permettront protéger toujours plus votre
iPhone n'oubliez pas les moins 15 % sur
tout le site de rhinoshield je vous mets
le lien en bas dans la description et il
faut taper le code gros 22 GRR 22 et
merci à rhinoshi d'avoir sponsorisé
cette vidéo on va commencer par regarder
la différence entre la première
génération et la deuxième génération
c'est vrai que la boîte elle est
quasiment identique je dis bien
quasiment parce qu'en réalité elle est
différente une vraie évolution et non il
y a pas une vraie évolution monsieur
Dreux il y a eu une évolution il y a eu
deux évolutions à vrai dire déjà on va
commencer par ça sur le côté ça c'est
quoi ce petit truc ça ça vous sert à
insérer une petite dragonne pour le
tenir l'attacher j'en sais rien moi des
clés un porte-clé à votre main est-ce
que vous voulez faire du yoyo avec si
vous voulez donc ça c'est côté dragon
qu'on avait pas avant je pense qu'Apple
se dit tiens il y a un usage il y a un
intérêt pourquoi pas les veulent
sécuriser bon ok on met une dragonne
autre petit truc qui est différent c'est
que sur la deuxième génération on vous a
mis ici un haut-parleur le haut-parleur
il servira quoi il servira à émettre un
son lorsque vous perdez votre boîte et
je sais pas si vous ça vous arrive mais
moi ça m'arrive si vous êtes du genre à
dire mais qu'est-ce que j'ai fait de
monter téléphone qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
de mes écouteurs et bien vous venez vous
allez sur votre application et paf vous
les trouvez et ça c'est vachement cool
donc ça c'est très pratique donc
regardez ici petit haut-parleur ok sinon
sur le reste et bien c'est quasiment la
même chose les deux boîtes sont très
identiques allez voir comme ça je sais
pas si vous allez savoir laquelle
laquelle allez je les prends hop hop hop
hop hop je tourne voilà laquelle est
laquelle vous le savez et ben voilà ça
moi je le vois pas en dessous ça c'est
airpods Pro 2 et ça c'est airpods Pro 1
ok alors maintenant je veux qu'on parle
un peu du design des airpods pro parce
que c'est aussi une chose qui a changé
enfin pas vraiment qui a changé qui a
évolué à peu la travailler sa copie en
se disant ok il faut que nos airpods Pro
2 soit meilleur fatalement meilleur au
niveau du son on s'en doutera nouvelle
puce H2 meilleur également au niveau de
la réduction de bruit active et du mode
transparent pourquoi bah tout simplement
pour vous profitez d'une meilleure
expérience on est quand même sur des
écouteur va falloir 299 € quasiment 300
euros autant vous dire qu'il faut quand
même qu'il y ait du travail qui est fait
alors regardez la différence vient se
rapprocher un petit peu ici sur les
airpods Pro 1 vous aviez votre petit
micro qui était là et vous aviez un
autre micro qui est à l'extérieur et
c'est ainsi que sur le r peut Pro 2 vous
avez votre micro qui se situe ici là
vous voyez et votre deuxième micro qui
se situe là sur le côté donc il y a un
petit travail qui est un peu différent
on les reconnaît parce que sur les deux
vous avez ces deux petits traits ici
tenez ce que là vous avez uniquement un
petit trait là et le deuxième qui va se
situer au niveau du K-pop présence donc
bon il y a un travail qui a été un peu
fait différemment au niveau du design
des produits pour améliorer tout ce qui
va être réduction de bruit active et le
mode transparent ok ça on voit donc bon
sinon franchement il se ressemble
énormément maintenant il y a un autre
truc qui a été changé alors je sais pas
ça se voit pas comme ça effectivement
c'est qu'ils ont rajouté des commandes
tactiles et les commandes tactiles je
trouve ça assez malin pour le coup
regardez je repose les r pote Pro 1 dans
leur petite boîte et on va se mettre de
la musique ici vous allez voir que tout
est quand même vachement vachement cool
puisque je vous parlais tout à l'heure
je regardais une vidéo sur Stupeflip on
va en profiter parce que il y a le
nouvel album qui est sorti Stupéflip
stup For Ever on va se mettre un peu de
son voilà donc moi j'ai du son vous
l'avez pas ce qui est plutôt normal ce
que je vous disais ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'effectivement ils
sont venus rajouter ici sur le côté
regardez vous rapprocher qui commande de
volume regardez là je baisse le volume
et là je monte le volume je tournerai ça
fait toc toc toc vous voyez j'y vais
cran par cran donc ça c'est quand même
vachement pratique vous voyez comme ça
hop là je peux venir faire ça maintenant
j'ai un autre mouvement effectivement
play pause post play raccrocher décroché
appuie long là je suis passé en mode
réduction bruit donc là ça vient me
couper du monde extérieur et lorsque je
le repasse pendant quelques secondes hop
je passe en mode transparence donc là
vous voyez hop réduction de bruit hop et
la mode transparence donc c'est comment
elles sont vraiment simples et je trouve
ça vraiment pratique en fait parce que
ce qui nous manquait avant c'était
vraiment le côté volume qui monte et qui
se baisse alors pour autant il y a un
truc et ça c'est un truc peut-être
améliorer pour une prochaine génération
c'est que le petit tactile voyez il est
vraiment intérieur il faut vraiment que
je vienne le chercher ici à l'intérieur
j'aurais tendance à vouloir venir
trouver ici je ne l'ai pas alors ça
évite les écouteurs je pense de venir
soit mettre play pause faut vraiment
venir le chercher à l'intérieur donc là
je viens je pose mon doigt contre le
bout de mon oreille ici et ça
XS vous avez le S vous avez le médium
qui est installé par défaut ici et vous
avez le l ce qui fait que tout un chacun
trouvera une taille qui conviendra à ses
oreilles et ça c'est très chouette alors
ici bien évidemment pas de bloc de
charge pas plus pas moins que dans un
smartphone vous avez votre câble c'est
du Lightning USB c ok ça marche le mode
transparence aussi très efficace lorsque
vous allez vous balader courir ici et ça
hop vous entendez tout ce qui se passe
autour de vous alors on nous dit que si
48000 adaptations du son par seconde ce
qui est quand même relativement énorme
comment ça marche vous avez donc deux
micros extérieurs je vous l'ai dit vous
en avez un là et vous en avez un sur le
dessus ici vous avez également un micro
à l'intérieur qui va venir analyser le
son dans votre règle le son qui arrive
de l'extérieur pour optimiser totalement
la réduction bruit ou le mode
transparence et ça fonctionne vraiment
bien il y a un autre qui sont venus
installer qui est vachement bien c'est
l'audio spatiale alors l'audio spatiale
comment ça marche regardez direct Island
ça vous le reconnaît comme ça après tu
peux venir appuyer je vois le niveau de
batterie et c'est quand même très très
pratique et ensuite pour l'audio
spatialisé j'ai qu'à venir ici je laisse
appuyer ici et là en bas je vais
retrouver mon audio spatialisé l'audio
spatial c'est comment vous dire ça va
venir élargir le son ça va venir
apporter beaucoup plus de volume à votre
son lorsque vous me le désactiver vous
avez un son droit de gauche classique
très bon son qui marche bien OK et
lorsque vous activez l'audio spécialisé
paf on a l'impression tout de suite de
repousser un peu les murs et d'avoir un
son qui va un peu plus loin alors je
l'ai écouté avec différentes marques il
y a différents produits il y a des
produits où j'ai pas trop aimé j'ai
trouvé que c'était pas super intéressant
sur la musique plutôt bien sur les films
et les séries mais ça m'en bats les pas
sur la musique ici je trouve qu'Apple a
bien bossé et sur la musique ça va je
l'ai activé ça me va bien parce que
j'écoute du son après il y a un autre
truc que je vous conseille de faire
uniquement lorsque vous écoutez des
films et des séries après vous me direz
ça dépend de chacun des goûts de chacun
c'est le suivi de la tête actif alors si
vous écoutez de la musique par exemple
là vous avez votre source qui est devant
vous tournez la tête vous allez avoir la
musique qui va rester par ici vous allez
vous déplacer autour alors il y a des
gens qui aimeront peut-être qui auront
l'impression d'être j'en sais rien moi
dans un concert moi ça me hype pas trop
moi ce que je préfère réellement c'est
laisser en fixe lorsque je vais écouter
de la musique et lorsque je regarde par
contre un film une série et bien je mets
celui-là je trouve assez marrant parce
que vous voyez ils sont vraiment quand
je me décale par rapport à mon téléphone
ou par rapport à ma tablette ou par
rapport à mon bac lorsque je regarde un
film donc ça c'est cool après ça
dépendra une fois de plus de tout un
chacun tout en sachant que cet audio
spatialisée et bien vous venez
paramétrer totalement à la forme de
votre oreille pour ce faire vous sortez
d'ici ensuite je viens dans mes réglages
ici et dans mes réglages j'ai mes
airpods pro je clique ici et là je
descends et là j'ai l'audio spatiale
personnalisée oui alors je l'ai déjà
fait en fait ce qui va se passer c'est
qu'il va venir d'abord vous reconnaître
grâce à votre caméra trueps à la vente
de votre smartphone donc il va regarder
votre tête de face ensuite il va vous
demander de scanner le haut le bas droit
de gauche et compagnie bon on connaît un
peu l'histoire comme on viendrait par
exemple régler face ID ensuite il vous
demande de scanner votre oreille de
droite il reconnaît votre oreille il
voit la forme ensuite votre oreille de
gauche et grâce à l'infrarouge il va
savoir exactement la forme de votre
oreille donc il va venir totalement
optimiser d'un point de vue logiciel
l'expérience audio-spatialisée par
rapport à votre oreille et c'est
totalement personnalisé alors je me
rends pas compte réellement de la
différence entre je le fais je le fais
pas ça fonctionne bien je suppose que
derrière il doit y avoir un vrai intérêt
puisqu'on est dans le côté applicatif je
vous le montre ça c'est une nouveauté
qui est intéressante aussi d'un point de
vue Software vous avez vos airpods que
vous trouvez là airpods pro et podmax ça
dépend de ce que vous avez en écouteur
ici tag vous appuyez vous venez
retrouver votre différent niveau de
charge le nom de vos airpods le contrôle
du bruit réduction de bruit transparence
et désactivé désactivez je n'ai pas
lorsque je switch ici mais là je peux
venir le mettre ici si je veux pincer la
tige des airpods donc contrôle du bruit
on peut se dire tiens je viens mettre
Siri au lieu d'avoir le contrôle du
bruit ok je peux venir ajouter en plus
le fait de désactiver la réduction de
bruit donc pas d'électronique je n'avais
pas comme ça par défaut mais je peux
venir mettre ici donc moi ce que je vous
conseille de faire c'est dans votre
partie de droite et bien hop là vous le
mettez celui-là vous l'activez parce que
si on veut désactiver l'électronique on
peut venir le faire et dans celui de
gauche vous venez mettre Siri comme ça
vous avez une expérience qui est
complète vous pouvez ensuite faire le
test d'ajustement des embouts si vous le
souhaitez ok la transparence adaptative
qui va venir s'adapter totalement par
rapport à ce qui va capter l'extérieur
la détection automatique des oreilles
l'audiospatialisée je vous ai montré le
micro chargement automatique toujours
celui de gauche toujours celui de droite
bon ok ça c'est relu l'espace sa petite
sauce recharge optimiser de la batterie
ok afficher localisée comme ça alors je
vous montre pas où je suis mais comme ça
je peux venir émettre un son lorsque je
vais le retrouver là je le vois devant
moi hop là et mettre un son
donc là il met le son uniquement dans
les dans les écouteurs j'ai aussi un
côté pour l'accessibilité vitesse de
l'appui plus lente par défaut durée du
maintien contrôle du bruit réduction du
bruit avec airpods autorisé les airpods
à passer en réduction de bruit lorsque
un seul airpods est utilisé ok c'est
plutôt pas mal suivre l'iPhone contrôle
du volume par défaut plus long maximal
volume de la tonalité donc il y a pas
mal de réglages aussi qui sont là pour
l'accessibilité ça c'est très cool et
puis ensuite vous avez des informations
sur la garantie si et ça et compagnie
autre élément qu'Apple est venu
améliorer ici c'est l'autonomie on monte
jusqu'à 6 heures d'autonomie avec un
écouteur par charge bien évidemment et
jusqu'à 30 heures au niveau de votre
coque avec la réduction de bruit active
activer que ce soit pour les 6 heures ou
pour les 30 heures donc on a une
autonomie qui est prolongée ok plutôt
pas mal et autre truc qui est pas mal
c'est les différents moyens de recharge
alors je voulais montrer tout à l'heure
dans la boîte vous avez du Lightning
vous pouvez venir le recharger
directement en Lightning en dessous ok
vous pouvez également venir les
recharger avec maxaf très facilement
vous avez du Maxi vous le posez ça le
recharge sans fil vous avez une Apple
watch vous pouvez venir le recharger
avec la recharge de votre APPLE watch
vous posez dessus et ça le recharge et
si vous avez un chargeur sans fil QI et
bien vous pouvez également venir le
charger avec autant vous dire qu'ici
vous avez un éventail de choix qui est
extrêmement large et autres trucs qu'on
va retrouver ici c'est la puce U1 qui
servira pour la localisation dans votre
voiture bien évidemment ici ils sont
certifiés IPX4 on résistant à l'eau et à
la transpiration l'idée c'est que vous
la pose trop vous allez prendre pour
aller courir faire du jogging aller en
salle de sport très facilement comme
vous le faisiez avec les airpods pro de
première génération donc de l'une à
l'autre là-dessus il y a absolument
aucune différence et je vous le dis les
airpods pro 2 sont disponibles au tarif
de 299 euros on est quasiment à 300
euros je trouve ça très cher très
honnêtement mais on est chez Apple et on
a l'habitude chez Apple d'avoir des
produits qui sont assez onéreux 299
euros sont plus chers la première
génération quand ils étaient sortis qui
était je crois un de mémoire à 249 euros
à peu près je crois qu'en est-il de la
qualité audio alors forcément un
policier est venu travailler pour
améliorer la qualité audio de ses
écouteurs on s'en doutera bien
évidemment alors qualitativement c'est
vrai qu'il y a une amélioration par
rapport à la génération précédente ça
vient les positionner un peu plus haut
remonte un peu plus tu mets déjà bien ce
qu'on avait avant sur la première
génération j'ai écouté pendant très
longtemps cette deuxième génération
alors je n'ai pas écouté pendant si
longtemps et j'ai pas passé six mois un
an avec qui viennent à peine de sortir
on s'en doutera néanmoins sauf qu'il y a
quand même un travail qui a été fait par
Apple on voit qu'ils ont gardé les mêmes
drivers mais cette nouvelle puce H2
permet de mieux travailler et
d'améliorer la qualité audio donc on a
un son qui est amélioré par rapport à la
première génération maintenant est-ce
que ce sont les meilleurs écouteurs j'ai
pu écouter sur des intras comme ça la
réponse est non mais ça vient quand même
les positionner dans les meilleurs
produits que j'ai pu écouter même si
c'est pas le haut du panier si vous
voulez des écouteurs si Apple pour avoir
une expérience 100% Apple et bien c'est
airpods Pro 2 sont cool marche bien
maintenant le truc à savoir c'est que
pour 299 € je trouve quand même cher par
rapport à ce qu'on retrouve sur
l'ensemble du marché mais si aujourd'hui
on vient acheter des airpods pro de
deuxième génération c'est qu'on est dans
l'écosystème Apple c'est qu'on veut une
expérience 100% Apple c'est que on aime
la marque et que on a un iPhone
probablement un iPad probablement un Mac
et qu'on veut les écouteurs les plus
haut de gamme chez Apple donc est-ce
qu'ils veulent le coup la réponse est
oui est-ce qu'ils sont chers oui très
cher est-ce qu'il faut y aller ça dépend
de vous si vous êtes Apple addict si
vous aimez les produits Apple bien vous
pouvez y aller parce qu'ils sont bien et
de bonnes factures ils marchent bien il
y a pas de souci là-dessus est-ce que le
rapport qualité prix est
pas trop ça reste quand même très cher
maintenant les produits sont cools il
marche bien dites-moi ce que vous en
pensez vous en bas en commentaire est-ce
que vous auriez envie d'acheter des
airpods pro deuxième génération d'Apple
est-ce qu'il vous tente est-ce que vous
aviez la première génération est-ce que
vous avez d'autres airpods autre que
l'air post pro des repas peut-être pas
et est-ce que vous avez envie de
switcher dites-le-moi juste en bas en
commentaire moi je trouve très cool un
peu cher mais on a l'habitude chez Apple
que les produits soient chers donc bon
rien de nouveau ici je vous embrasse
prenez soin de vous et à très bientôt
Ciao
[Musique]